at halloween salem massachusetts may as
well be
the north pole at christmas trick or
treat
and while the pandemic has added a new
variety of masks to the mix
and cut down on the numbers the spirit
remains
why is this so special around halloween
i think it's the
glamour of being the what they consider
the witch city
the people that come they're all dressed
up they're happy
they're having a great time bob
birkenshaw and jackie russell okay
just need a signature here are at the
center of it all
this is raspberry jelly snowball cream
as
owners of salem's ye old pepper company
candy store
a lot of good stuff usually the lines
are endless
the father-daughter duo are third and
fourth generation candy makers
who still make the same sweet
temptations as their company's founder
the history is very important that's
where we came from that's where our
company
started even the equipment that we use
dates back to the 1800s that's how far
back
ye olde pepper company traces its
history to an english woman named mary
spencer
who arrived in america in 1806 after
being shipwrecked
she was destitute she landed in salem
and her neighbors asked if there was
anything they could do for her
and she said if you could give me some
sugar
i can make some candy and i can start to
support myself so they donated a barrel
of sugar to her
and she started making her gibraltar's
she started selling them on the church
steps
soon turning her gibraltars into what's
believed to be the country's first
commercially sold candy
confectioner george pepper bought the
business and by 1830
created a companion treat and he decided
that the gibraltar
was sort of a feminine piece of candy
it was made dainty it was made in lemon
and peppermint flavors
so he decided to make a candy called the
blackjack
made from blackstrap molasses more
mammal this was more manish
birkenshaw's grandfather bought the
company from pepper at the turn of the
20th century
birkenshaw's father would later take it
over and move
production into the family basement from
like four years old all you could smell
through the whole house was candy
that's like a kid's dream
all the neighborhood kids used to come
over and they'd all hang around the
windows looking for the
samples to come out which my father used
to always you know pass out the window
to them so how
young were you then when you learned to
make candy i would say maybe around 10.
and he's still making it today now the
kitchen sits adjacent to the store's
shop
allowing its sugary aroma to entice
customers
birkenshaw passing on recipes to his
son-in-law
just as his father and grandfather had
done before
like lemon drops made the old-fashioned
way
and of course there are the gibraltars
mary spencer's
same recipe made as she would have back
in the 1800s
isn't there an easier way to do it
though now oh there is definitely an
easier way
this is not a business to be in if
you're looking for an easy business an
easy way to work
but there's something about maintaining
that history in that tradition
and that's what makes us keep going
ready yeah
and while the historic confections
remain ye old pepper company's biggest
sellers
the candy business is one of creativity
and innovation
we're always trying to come up with
something different something to go with
the seasons
or just new ideas creativity is also
what helped keep the business going
when the pandemic hit back in march we
laid everybody off
we shut everything down and my father
and i went to work and tried to figure
out exactly what we were going to do
and we were a little panicked we have
all this easter candy and i
actually called my son school i said to
them you know
would you mind you know putting out an
email to the parents
we will make baskets from scratch they
basically saved us at the beginning
they were the reason we were able to
continue going mary spencer started this
because the community reached out and
gave her sugar right so she could do
that right
in your time of need you reached out to
the community right yes
st michaels was a lifeline
[Laughter]
and now in october the lifeline is quite
simply
the line even at a third of its normal
size
with safety precautions in place it's an
extremely big deal
we actually did not plan we did not plan
for a large halloween
so we're you know around the clock we're
making candy we're
packing candy trying to keep up with
everything
just like the gibraltars which started
it all ye old pepper company continues
to stand the test of time i don't see
candy going out anytime
soon but you know fingers crossed my
grandfather made it through the great
depression and he lost everything
but he still he still kept going good
job you got
it you're hired i'm hoping to continue
it for my son someday
ultimately it's his decision but i'm
keeping it running right now so that
someday
he has the option same way your dad did
yep it's truly in our blood
with every gibraltar and blackjack you
eat right
true